we started FM for credit morrow we
started it by looking at flat rate loads
and under fee remember because there's
only couple ways here I'm hoping
remember that when you see the word or
the phrase rather flat rate loans you
think back to all of the like financial
maths that you are that you did in the
earlier in the year and the United 10
and you should think single interest
once you've got simple interest of your
mind you're like oh I know this isn't
interesting is it is I equals so yeah
okay this is cool this is not hot the
problem so we start a different for
looking at flat rate loans we're gonna
end and fit or look at this thing called
present and future value these the
abbreviations we use present value
future value and in a very similar way
when you see flatlines you think simple
interest when you see present if future
value you should think compound interest
okay so this is not it's not crazy new
stuff but it is phrased in a different
way the language of the questions will
be just a little bit off at an angle and
we know in mathematics general and in as
in real life the way you interpret
things is is actually sometimes the the
lion's share of the question so I want
you to remember with me compound
interest sugar cookies color just like
simple interest has its formula I'll
give you a tip it's done three than a
this is for compound interest what's the
rest of it RUP Frank its water plus very
good okay so you remember this and
you've got your formative data sheet
seeing you in front of you so hopefully
it's on you'll actually see it there we
go on the first page it immediately
follows the simple interest formula okay
now I want to point out two things
firstly just to jog your memory
when you have a look at the right-hand
side of each of these formulas when you
look at the right-hand side you can see
it's got the same three pieces of
information do you notice that right
it's still got the principal it's still
but your interest rate and it still got
n which is what is it number of
compounding periods right well your
periods isn't where it's saying okay so
five years 60 months whatever happens to
be but one thing that's very very
different is that here the simple
interest formula calculates the interest
for you so remember we'll look at some
questions last time and it's like what's
the total value that I have to pay off
for something and you can go ahead you
can work out the interest but that
you've got to add back to that the
principal if you've got like a credit
card debt and you're paying off the
whole Bank this principal is interest
you're working out separately you can
combine where is this guy over here this
formula includes a what do we usually
think of painter standing for you know
amount usually so puts an heiress here
for me because this principal
this is where the account starts
especially this is the value at the
beginning right and then the amount like
you just said is where the account ends
so you can see built-in sense formulas
kind of like the passage of time right
you start somewhere you're in somewhere
and that includes the original amount
and the interest that you are not that
so all we got to do to change my which
are this into this prison future value
business is that note that where they
can't start that's the present value
right now and when he cut ends that's
the future value what it's going to be
okay so I'm just going to rewrite this
same formula this is the future value
over here and when the accountant this
is going to be watch right now the resin
value P V and then because it it
operates on compound interest principles
and it's exactly the same thing over
here which is why when you have a look
at your formula Donna she directly
underneath the club had interest formula
there it is have a look on the
right-hand side you'll notice too that
have F V and P be together I'll talk
about both in a second but just have a
look at the right-hand one do you see it
that's what it is it's all that is
it's just dressed up very very slightly
differently okay now what these formula
lets you do is if you ignore the present
value any interest rate and the number
of compounding periods then you can work
out what your being the future okay but
sometimes we want to do planning right
it's like oh I want to save up to have
this or I want to be able to work out
can I pay off that loan in the future
right so sometimes I don't want to know
like discover solve what the future
value is I know what this is supposed to
be and I want to find out its so what we
do is we just rearrange this formula
slightly if I divide both sides by this
one plus R to the N field if I divide
the left hand side and the right hand
side
what's going to happen on the left hand
side I'm just gonna get FB on so it's
gonna so pop over there and we need to
buy this it just sort of goes away so it
just becomes so easy this formula it's
the same formula it's the same idea but
it's like hey if I know what the future
value should be and I know the interest
rate is the naree how long I got to get
there then I can use those three things
to work out all how much am I going to
need to invest how much am I gonna have
to start with and these two here are
what you find on your formula and data
[ __ ] so they're not they're not two
different formulas in fact they're not
even a new formula it's just the
previous formula up to compound interest
one just stated in slightly different
language it does that make sense
okay let's completed two examples just
to jog your memory on - wait so he's
example one I want to draw your
attention to you I'm gonna do sort of
like an exam technique thing here I'm
not just going to show you how to solve
the question I want you to think what do
you think is the easiest part of this to
get wrong what do you think is the most
common error that students make on a
question okay and you all identify
because we've all done this before right
you go through this yeah cool I know how
to go through this formula and I see
what the rate is
I see what the amount of time is and
they use for instance radio okay so we
don't slow down and realize wait this
means you should all underline this this
means I've got to do something
differently so here's my exam check need
to train to come back the first thing I
do before I launch into the formula
because I know as soon as I start down
this path my brain just kind of goes on
autopilot and I stop thinking okay the
first thing we're going to do is I'm
gonna think about
time okay so the first thing I wanna
know is okay
compounding periods and how many are
there right so what's the number of in
this instance the compounding period is
a month so what's the number of months
that's actually going to elapse going to
pass in the time span of this question
it's 24 right so I'm just gonna write
down two times twelve two years twelve
months per year that gives you that
number and then along with the number of
months I want to know the interest per
month because as you guys recognize it's
not just the end that changes the are
changes along with it right so instead
of getting 0.08 it's going to be divided
by twelve
very good now if you go ahead and you
put that into your calculator I think
it's gonna hand you this okay so that
number there zero point zero six six six
repeat or something like that that is
our rate per month and this is how many
months I've got so now that I've sorted
that out now I'm going to find out the
value
okay so the reason why I couldn't look
like this rather than as this is another
zero isn't there any of them yet is
because I'm about to pop this into the
calculator right and I can't put this
into the calculator I can't type
successful I can but I don't want to
type it forever this is a lot I start to
write sometimes you'll see in the next
question you get a decimal and it
doesn't it doesn't recur it just stops
in which case well you might as well
just write that it's nice and easy to
calculate this is just a practical thing
okay so now I'm going to go to work out
with my president future value formula I
want the future value and I know the
present value is right there
25 dozen or so I'm gonna go 25 1 plus
here's what I've calculated the right to
be each compounding period and here is
how many compounding periods there are
okay now just in the psyche you don't
need to make this but if you're in a
hurry and you feel confident with this
and you can demonstrate yeah I know what
I'm doing with this at this point here
like you don't have to do this as a
separate step you could write this all
in one here right
twenty-five thousand one plus is the
interest that you see I've included
months in that and then here is the
number of months in total right so do
you see how that sort of chopped this
sorry all of these steps into here okay
now the reason I put this on this on the
side and in red and astronauts write it
is because when we trust ourselves to do
this all in one here we forget we don't
do anything right and this is a common
area and you come back and look man you
to do that and I was just watching okay
so as an example step out of this and
get into the rhythm of time down time
value that helps you get the hardest
part
correct once you've done that whichever
Road you go by you punch inspector and
out pops a number which is twenty nine
twenty nine thousand three 322 and okay
so now I'm going to ground okay and by
the way that's a perfect moment to
remember like this is an easy way to see
doesn't make sense or not it's future
value it should be growing so if I get
two dozen hundred because I'd like just
fumble two months on the calculator I
know something's going wrong because I
heard my bank account like wow that's
really bad inflation that's a great
question
so why don't we just have a look at this
and say if we adjust in it adjusted a
rather quarterly means quarterly
meetings there are four quarters in a
year four quarters in a year
so therefore I don't even need to think
about like is it three months or four
months I just think about here the
number of quarters is going to be not
two times twelve it'll be two times four
because that's what a quarter means
right there are four of them so there
will be eight quarters in total the
interest per quarter will be 0.08
divided by four and the advantage of
doing it that way is you can do that
with any kind of time scale you like
like if you had some really crazy Bank
which is like we compound your interest
you know once every 19 30 years you're
like how many how many days is that
gonna be I don't care I just changed
this to be you know two times nineteen
and I change this to 0.08 divided life
just doesn't matter